[Music]
and what were you thinking news what in
the way what had anything you're doing
submitted by Japanese denim Japanese a
badass all good Daniel sees are a bus
company is being investigated by the
Illinois Attorney General after its
online advertisement insulted Asia I saw
this one the Chinese bus one yeah okay
tell me to detail so there's this ad I
was emailed to customers of this company
and this companies call it suburban
Express I don't know I've already
laughing it's gonna be really offensive
or really funny good yeah I love racism
by the way it's one of my guilty
pleasures people gets so angry but I
love it because of the creativity or
it's just so ridiculous
that's ridiculous I mean like yeah it's
like yeah go on before I get myself more
[ __ ] in trouble I couldn't answer it
okay got it moving on so this is a bus
company that services students of the
University of Illinois mm-hmm this was
the email that they send out hey you
chase and it's just listing like why
this company is better than their
competitors okay and one of the the
bullet points here they said passengers
like you you won't feel like you're in
China when you're on our buses doesn't
matter it just sounds great yeah what
does that mean actually I think it's
crowded because there's a lot of Chinese
people that started going to that school
and using the bus system so the locals
are like what happened to my bus it used
to be Americans now it's a bunch of
ching ching chong is all over where I'm
at okay let that deter say some [ __ ]
like you're not gonna smell like
mothballs and I would have [ __ ]
laughed but that was just poor yeah they
said that right and immediately they got
so much backlash for that email and so
they emails an apology it better be good
though sorry Ching chongs
even half the email apart because I feel
like I get what they're saying if I got
a letter like that I was like it's not
gonna feel like you're in China oh my Oh
awesome yeah so now my picture of what
it's gonna feel like it's that much
clearer it's like it might look like
Africa or it might look like Europe or
it might look like America well
especially in this climate right now I
did not immediately think oh it's gonna
be African bus yeah because it's like
process of elimination right it's like
hey try this new mystery drink it's not
like sprite they know like oh cool so
I'm gonna wipe the sprite tastebuds out
of my mouth and I'm gonna search for a
Coke or vodka sounds racist so they're
now placing like you're not gonna be
like in China you're not gonna feel like
your antenna so then I immediately so
eliminates the China scenery but I don't
think anybody goes oh I'm gonna be on a
Russian bus tomorrow Bart does I do I
mean they could have easily said like oh
we meant not like in China where you
know it's really crowded and Chinese
buses or they could have gone that route
but instead this is what they said in
their apology high apology a little
while ago we sent out an email that has
received some negative feedback it's
already bad wait till you're surprised
it gets better as I go along
we made a remark based on the fact that
our competitor mostly handles Chinese
international students the remark is
being interpreted as a slap in the face
of all non-caucasians for some reason
and for some reason it was intended
we must concede that we disagree with
the way the University of Illinois is
being run U of I is a state school that
is funded by taxpayers and is built on
land granted by the people of the state
of Illinois the LAT people as such we
believe that the mission of the
University of Illinois should be
providing high quality affordable
education to the citizens of Illinois U
of I mismanagement over the past few
decades has put them in a financial bind
to solve the problem they admit large
numbers of international students who
pay higher tuition nearly 20% of U of I
students are natives of China and this
high percentage of non-native
english-speakers
places a variety of burdens on domestic
students does it have to do with the
[ __ ] comment about the I understand
Adam
why did we agree that having a healthy
mixture of different cultures and
ethnicities is valuable but we're not
comfortable with the idea of selling our
university to the highest born bidder in
any event we didn't yeah that's what
they did because of the mismanagement of
the finances yeah and then they finish
it off and we did not intend to offend
half the planet regards suburban Express
[ __ ] so is all the Chinese people that
were complaining hey what do you mean by
that is that the half of the planet
they're talking about no like a lot of
people they could have just been like oh
is the slip up and we made a mistake we
shouldn't is that China but that email
proves their motive Factory which was
they intended to hurt yeah you know what
they're doubling down on that yeah you
know you know when people have
legitimate issues but they [ __ ] it all
up because that is actually a legitimate
concern if I being an American saw all
these foreigners coming into my
University and I'm like what the [ __ ]
what about my kids I pay taxes we've
been here for like eight generations
what the [ __ ] right but to direct your
anger toward the students that's [ __ ]
ridiculous do it to the school
[ __ ] yeah what does what the
foreign students have anything to do
with anything
yeah they just want to come here to
enjoy it and maybe some of them will
stay and become citizens who knows but
them directing that anger and energy
toward the [ __ ] students is that's
where it goes all wrong yeah you're
doing through the wrong person doing
those talk [ __ ] about the school
whatever they don't even speak English
they can't defend themselves it's also
weird that they like reveal all these
flaws in their business plan like we
pretty much [ __ ] up so that's how we
gotta make money now yeah but that final
dig was half of the planet we just to
say you're overpopulated change yeah I
like apologies where they come out under
like hey man tomorrow I'm gonna kill
myself
because I [ __ ] up I wanna [ __ ] stab
my guts out take my entrust and title
but it's not an archeology yeah that's
not an apology at all that was just like
well let me further prove my [ __ ] I
don't even think the first email need an
apology I was like okay coolest I look
like China perkupp us I would respect
them more if they came out and said
honestly I don't want more chinks in my
neighborhood this is
right there hope respect them even more
because there being a conjurer
possession this [ __ ]
passive-aggressive racism [ __ ] that
middle ground well we're not racist but
like we're kind of tired of all these
Chinese people moving into our
neighborhood like [ __ ] that [ __ ] I hope
your bus company
breaks down and whoever owes it ends up
getting [ __ ] in the ass for no reason
I think also that it shouldn't be
directed to just if they're saying they
don't want the university to be sold to
the highest bidder
you know it shouldn't just be directed
at Chinese kids just because the
University of Illinois has a large know
with all the Filipino get in the nursing
program yeah what are all the white
people in Business Administration
[Laughter]
Business Administration
yeah well the school has 13% Asian but
are they Chinese nationals or are they
Asian Americans in 12% speed no
affirmative action doesn't work for East
Asians it actually works against us and
the reason for that is because there's
too many of us especially in the UC
system you know or whatever yeah we
there's too many so now in order to get
into college East Asians have to be
super exceptional straight A's plus
electives and all these other extra
things and a job in [ __ ] oh I [ __ ]
struggle my daddy [ __ ] killed me and
I went back to the way I'm Jesus Christ
yeah because everybody has the same sob
story right learn oh we were poor and
then we struggled it's like well tell me
what Asian hasn't [ __ ] done that [ __ ]
I'm Cambodian yeah you come here so hard
that my arms fell off and then I got it
reattached again and then now I'm back
yeah like they want to hear stories like
that you I student affairs tweeted this
out and it says hello
[Laughter]
sorry sorry no this is from the
university they said we we cannot
prevent a private company from operating
in our community but we can loudly and
unambiguously say that the opinions
expressed by suburban express our
offensive bigoted insulting and in
direct opposition to the values of this
university and we would encourage any
potential future customers of this
transport company to carefully
investigate its record and customer
concerns before using its services so
now the Illinois Attorney General issued
a subpoena to suburban Express seeking
documents records and information that
will help determine whether the
company's policies and practices violate
state law so their electrons
yeah discriminatory practices I hope the
whole company shuts down yeah yeah that
is kind of shady though because what if
you are a Chinese foreign exchange
student and you know you you start
feeling uncomfortable taking this bus
because every time you get on you get
bullied and picked on just [ __ ]
blowing his nose
[ __ ] spitting on the bus and I'm like
get the [ __ ] off this bus to do it like
hey get the [ __ ] off this bus chee
cheong [ __ ] right by myself angry at all
the Chinese people how you guys feel
about those like that special bus system
in Hawaii like only for Japanese
tourists like maybe well I thought
that's a tour company Tori yeah it's not
a kowai saying this is a Japanese all
Japanese it's a tour company I want to
get on that bus no I tried I tried
when I first into wieck's I didn't know
is Japanese only like or I guess because
what they told me that's what they told
me cuz I'm like how do we get on that
bus they're like oh no that's only for
Japanese tourists and I'm like you could
probably book it but you won't
understand [ __ ] yeah that's that's the
problem
oh it could be that they just do
everything in Japanese language yeah I'm
pretty sure what it is yeah cuz I see
Chinese buses here all the time and I
don't know what the [ __ ] man wears
equal-opportunity [ __ ] that's
wrong [ __ ] tour guys are dope
especially when you see you know what we
went to the it was it Duluth Palace of
Versailles man those [ __ ] are
trained in so many different languages
they're just sitting that this is white
dude he's speaking like Mandarin they
start speaking Korean it's [ __ ] dope
dude so [ __ ] multi-talented as hell
what kind of services would you provide
if you had your own bus company [ __ ]
oh that was fast
yeah kind of what about food oh yeah do
you expected I'm not thinking about
myself I'm thinking about the customer I
would love food so you're only gonna
have mill customers you know Lina women
blow job you're gonna have to clean up
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] all the time that's
all coming no no coming everyone's a
swallower mommy no coming before you get
to the bus before you get on the bus you
have to masturbate frequently before you
get there
no pre-cum no nothing there's already
too many rules you should already went
no no no no no I don't want that smother
what is a come bus and then now you
don't wanna say it was a come bus I said
a [ __ ] bus and dirty no cop you
understand don't carve it yeah you get a
four swipe from that wow that's
embarrassing
that's on you yeah I got an email that
says there's no coming on this bus then
that's eliminating dude I'm saying now
no no I still don't understand the
concept part I don't so you know it's so
when you're trying to guess something
when there's a mystery you don't know
what's gonna happen they tell you they
go this is not gonna be a block didn't
you erase that out of your mouth well
could then what is assumed is that
you're gonna be uncomfortable with the
[ __ ] pumpkin spice latte a lot see
but you're probably like well I had no
problem with it in the first place maybe
I do want it well even if I have a
problem I don't I just now know it's not
part of my selection but why should it
even be on your thought product that
they go alone but if then once someone
told me if you get on this bus no one's
gonna Jack you off on my cool I'm not
gonna [ __ ] come on this bus now
should be the rivers know-it-all but you
being Chinese and you go on yeah being
what Chinese
it is
I got dry [ __ ] mouth and then some
saliva came and went but you being
Chinese you go on the [ __ ] bus and
everyone looks at you and go hey I
thought we're not supposed to feel like
we're in China anymore and then door
looking at getting a [ __ ] off [ __ ]
any better I didn't read the email my
bad I thought I wasn't gonna feel like
I'm in China only mail to me I'm the
only person that got the email for the
time I talked about cuz I'm pretty sure
in Beijing there's hella way people oh I
thought I was on a tour bus but not in
China huh yeah just convoluted [ __ ] gets
but that's how my braid things if you
tell me there's no lunch on the awesome
[Music]